yeah ten minutes after I posted my
review of the PS Vita system the new
trailer for the Avengers came out and
well I ain't missing this so what I saw
there was a new trailer for the Avengers
I thought alright it hasn't been that
long since the Super Bowl spot so I
thought it was gonna be like the Super
Bowl trailer just like a minute longer
new whole new trailer and as the trailer
before it and the trailer before it it
just looks better and better so the
Avengers movies about two months away
now this is the final trailer and it
shows it shows all the members of The
Avengers getting recruited like Nick
Fury goes to Captain America Scarlett
Johansson goes to Bruce Banner I need
you to come in right there I'd be like
yeah okay yeah I'm a week for scarlet
Joe and what I like is that it addressed
something that I thought because you
know an Iron Man 2 it was like oh you
can't be an Avenger because you're
narcissistic and unstable and we can't
have you this trailer addresses that
fact I thought I didn't qualify
apparently I'm volatile self-obsessed
and don't play I like that it's not like
something that they're just like oh no
no he's an Avenger because he is and
after that it is just a montage of
Awesome I mean stuff that you're like oh
that's so great oh wow that happened
that's awesome dude that just happened
incredible it just gets better and
better the trailer just amps up there's
a part where you're like oh dude that's
actually kind of emotional all right
back to badass the Iron Man has a few
scenes in this trailer I guess that's my
only gripe I wouldn't even call it a
gripe but I just wish they'd show more
of Captain America every trailer seems
to focus on Iron Man however the dude
flies and he's in an iron suit and he's
narcissistic and awesome so I guess why
wouldn't they
we're not a team we're a time bomb
and you see a little more about the
destructive machine The Incredible Hulk
you know what I like about him is he
actually looks like Mark Ruffalo Hey
look at the guy's face you're like yeah
that actually looks like Mark Ruffalo I
didn't think the other Incredible Hulk
looked like Edward Norton this one
you're like oh yeah that was Mark
Ruffalo now it's really big green Mark
Ruffalo I think that's cool I like that
there's scenes I'm not gonna show you
here you just need to watch the trailer
and be like oh okay that's awesome and
I'm seeing it for the first time here
Jeremy didn't spoil out on his video
that's good news I'll still show you a
few things and of course we got my boy
we got Loki I'm telling you guys I can't
see the feature but I'm just saying you
reviewers 2013 possible Best Villain
nomination right here and you call such
lost creatures
you have made me very desperate
that's when you know Loki's like yep
look at my suit I'm Finn at this point
this is the first movie of the summer
that we have a final trailer for and
this is what final trailer should do
they should be so awesome and badass
that they make you forget about every
other trailer for every movie this
summer what's coming at this summer I
haven't forgotten about Dark Knight
Rises that's the one I haven't forgotten
about and then when the trailer resolves
you're like okay this is awesome this is
the best thing ever and then Ironman
brings around the corner something from
the Shadow of the Colossus are you
serious they're fighting really big
machine worm ships
I think the Avengers are gonna die
they're not gonna kill anyone ah I'm
just saying it looks pretty dire death
destruction big shadow of the colossi
ships and locate this is exactly what I
was hoping for for The Avengers trailer
so have you seen The Avengers trailer I
will put a link below you go check that
[ __ ] out you come back here you comment
below let me know what you think
check out my PS Vita review because in
the way YouTube set up it probably got
buried because I did this video in any
case if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]